je veux pas être brusque je veux
simplement vous dire que
moi je veux pas être bon derrière va
avoir mal généralement non mais pour
être très clair tout ce qui a été dit
jusqu'à présent
je vous le dis très clairement il n'y
aura pas de coupure d'électricité
ni par le compteur ni autrement il n'y
aura pas de coupure d'eau il n'y aura
pas de coupure d'eau chaude liée à la
situation je crois qu'il faut vraiment
rassurer l'ensemble de nos
téléspectateurs j'en suis certain
pourquoi Laurent il y a des entreprises
qui ont reçu des mails leur disant entre
le 15 octobre et le 15 mars on risque on
risque de couper l'électricité c'est
indépendant du sujet sur lequel je viens
de voir ce soir je crois qu'il faut
qu'on soit bien sûr
parce que ça si ça nous intéresse aussi
on pourra parler mais ce qu'il faut
quand même dire par rapport au sujet qui
nous prie que ce soir Cyril c'est que ça
concerne déjà qui ça concerne je crois
que c'est important de le dire ça
concerne les personnes les gens qui ont
un cumulus pour chauffer l'eau un
cumulus c'est un ballon d'eau chaude qui
chauffe en général la nuit d'accord et
ça chauffe la nuit et la journée on a de
l'eau chaude ça s'appelle un cumulus un
ballon d'eau chaude qui marche à
l'électricité certaines ne marchent pas
à l'électricité là ça ne concerne que
cela d'accord et ces gens-là en général
ces personnes là ont un contrat
d'électricité qui s'appelle Heartland
earthrose je crois que tout le monde
connaît ça leur planeur creuse c'est à
dire qu'il y a les heures pleines et 8
heures par jour c'est les heures creuses
donc ils sont un peu moins cher d'accord
sur la facture et ces heures creuses en
général elles sont le soir d'accord le
soir parce que l'électricité est moins
cher le soir et quelquefois elles sont
aussi entre midi et deux
méridienne d'accord et qu'est-ce qui se
passe entre midi et deux vous vous
l'avez dit tout à l'heure Gilles il y a
des il y a l'hiver est un peu tendu on
le sait on a eu des infos divers est un
peu tendus
quoi faire attention c'est les moments
où tout le monde consomme en même temps
et ces moments où tout le monde consomme
en même temps c'est en général entre et
le soir quand on rentre entre la maison
et donc on s'est dit les gens qui
chauffent l'eau entre midi et deux c'est
peut-être pas utile ça va nous être si
on évitait de chauffer l'eau entre midi
et deux ça va nous aider à partir
de là
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
c'est que vous coupez les ballons de
choses chez les gens sans leur
consentement vous rentrez dans
l'intimité dans les appartements des
gens dans les maisons des gens sans leur
dire
Linky c'est on a l'espion dans la maison
ça me dit pas le contraire
nous espionne ah ouais ah oui c'est
d'ailleurs
non mais je crois qu'il faut prendre le
temps de sujet sérieux
je crois qu'il faut vraiment se donner
quelques instants pour le comprendre
sans polémiquer il s'agit de de
maintenir l'électricité tout au long de
l'hiver et d'éviter ce qu'on appelle les
pointes c'est à dire les surprises
on sait très bien qu'il y aura des
coupures tout le monde le sait en tout
cas ce que je peux vous dire c'est que
nous nous organisons oui service public
de la distribution nous faisons en sorte
que ça ne se produise pas et c'est pour
cela que entre midi et deux on va
décaler
la réchauffe des cumulus d'accord et les
cumulus ils vont chauffer la nuit tout
simplement et on aura l'eau chaude toute
la journée comme avant
une suspension électrique entre midi et
deux des appareils électriques non pas
des appareils électriques uniquement du
réchauffage un communiqué là j'ai un
communiqué enedis qui dit à la demande
de RTE et des pouvoirs publics enedis
suspendra temporairement du 15 octobre
au 15 avril 2023 le déclenchement
automatique des appareils électriques
liés aux heures creuses de 12 heures à
14h et les appareils liés aux heures
creuses c'est pour l'essentiel dans 90
non j'ai apparaît électrique tout les
appareils
les appareils électriques
à la demande de RTE et des pouvoirs
publics et nudistes suspendra
temporairement du 15 octobre 2022 au 15
avril 2023 le déclenchement automatique
des appareils électriques liés aux
heures creuses les appareils électriques
liés aux heures creuses c'est que les
chauffeurs c'est que les chauffe-eau
vous êtes sûrs je suis certain
du tout c'est pas la lumière le
chauffe-eau en fait historiquement
qu'est-ce pourquoi est-ce qu'on fait ça
parce que historiquement l'électricité a
toujours été produite tout le temps et
la nuit on l'utilise moins donc il y a
plus d'éléments
réchauffe l'eau
réchauffe la nuit Cyril on réchauffe
l'eau la nuit et on l'utilise la journée
c'est tout simplement ça donc ça ne
change rien pour l'ensemble des des
utilisateurs et je peux juste te dire
une chose c'est que vous savez il y a il
y a une association de consommateurs qui
s'appelle l'UFC Que Choisir qui est il y
a pas toujours été très fort avec nous
sur le compteur préféré elle a dit elle
a dit c'est un bon moyen d'éviter les
coupures électriques cet hiver donc
quand les chauffe-eau c'est bien mais
vous trouvez pas qu'il y a une grosse
injustice quand même liberté égalité
fraternité c'est chez nous ça c'est pas
ailleurs liberté égalité égalité 4
millions 3 pourquoi 4 millions 3 et pas
les autres il faudrait pas que c'est une
injustice quand même vous allez punir
4003 et comme ma liberté vous allez
rentrer chez les gens pour piloter toi
tu feras pas si trop alors la bonne
nouvelle c'est que les chauffe-eau midi
entre midi et 14h les mecs ils prennent
pas ça va aller mais ça commence
l'histoire mais pourquoi que 4 millions
3 de France ça veut dire tout ce qu'on
fait confiance à Linky qu'on a traité de
complotistes à l'époque vous leur donnez
raison en fait enfin fallait pas faire
confiance absolument pas je crois qu'il
faut vraiment que que vous compreniez
une chose c'est que ce qui est fait là
c'est pour justement passer l'hiver en
tranquillité je suis d'accord et le
compteur Linky il a rien au contraire au
contraire ok vous pouvez couper ou pas
sans compteur que vous pouvez couper
est-ce que système est-ce que vous allez
faire mais absent on ne coupe pas on ne
coupe pas on ne coupe rien sans compteur
Linky on aurait pu faire exactement la
même chose c'est-à-dire ne pas envoyer
le signal qui enclenche le chauffe-eau
et le chauffe-eau électrique d'accord
mais grâce au compteur quand même grâce
au compte au contraire
des gens qui ont les heures creusent
entre midi devant continuer à pouvoir en
bénéficier des heures creuses pour la
cuisson pour le four donc ça c'est
vachement est-ce que tu peux relire ton
truc là
parce que il y a des gens qui disent
pourquoi vous dites pas tout simplement
les chauffe-eau oui
21h02 bah c'est de retrouver déjà
le terme ce sont les chauffe-eau
électrique alors vous me dites moi je
suis chaud bah vas-y à la demande à la
demande de RTE et des pouvoirs publics
enedis suspendra temporairement du 15
octobre 2022 au 15 avril 2023 le
décochement le déclenchement automatique
des appareils électriques
ceux qui sont déclenchés par les heures
creuses et ne sont déclenchés par les
heures creuses que les cumulus
voilà si vous porte parole Bénédicte
vous pouvez nous affirmer là que ce sera
uniquement les chauffe-eau de 12h à 14h
avec 4 millions de personnes ils vont
s'en remettre je pense c'est pas très
grave grave seulement si c'est quand
même un truc une intrusion
il y a un truc que je vais vous dire
c'est que non seulement je vous
l'affirme clairement et si demain vous
vous venez vous pouvez me joindre vous
pouvez me réinterroger et j'aurai
exactement un position mais en plus de
ça ce que ce que je vais vous dire sur
le compte vous parlez tous du compteur
Linky mais grâce au comptable qui chacun
de nous aujourd'hui on a 35 millions en
France chacun des clients peut disposer
d'informations sur sa consommation et ça
aussi ça va nous aider à passer parce
que si on maîtrise notre consommation on
va pouvoir mieux la contrôler ça c'est
vraiment quelqu'un qui dit un truc
intéressant mais si le ballon d'eau
chaude
de chauffe pas entre midi et deux il va
consommer plus publicité la nuit pour
attraper ceux de notre million d'eux non
parce qu'en fait il a il va une fois
qu'il est l'eau est chaude il s'arrête
en général une fois la nuit il va
chauffer il a besoin de trois quatre
cinq heures pour faire selon les cumulus
il y a des cumulus de 50 à 300 je veux
prendre une douche à 18h l'eau elle est
froide ou elle est chaude mais non elle
est Frade elle sera chaude dans le
ballon
de la prend pas devant nous
non pardon mais je suis extrêmement
inquiet du moment qu'on est en train de
vivre on est en train de se demander si
on va pouvoir utiliser de l'eau chaude
cet hiver on va pouvoir se chauffer moi
j'en ai marre qu'on nous affranchise que
les membres du gouvernement se prennent
pour nos darons ça fait deux ans qui
nous ont ils nous ont dit pas de masse
pas sortir pas si maintenant c'est col
roulé faire ci pas de chauffage passant
on vous donne des ordres comme des
gamins c'est insupportable mais
qu'est-ce qu'on a fait pour mériter ça à
la gare en Ukraine
non mais arrêtez non mais c'est ça
c'est très bien moi aussi spécialiste
géopolitique là
vous êtes brillant vous voulez nous
rassurer mais moi vous paniquez je vais
vous expliquer pourquoi j'aborde dans le
comice que lui il prend des douches la
nuit déjà
à la demande des pouvoirs publics donc
ça ça veut dire que c'est le
gouvernement qui vous a alerté qui vous
a dit faites quelque chose rien ne va
plus couper les ballons d'eau chaude et
là vous nous rassurez vous dites il y
aura pas de problème mais moi je vous
pose la question toute simple s'il y a
pas de problème pourquoi vous coupez les
ballons d'eau chaude c'est vrai voilà
je récré pas l'histoire ah pas du tout
non mais pour retourner
un truc en plus c'est une question par
l'absurde excusez-moi mais quand vous
dites ça moi je vous dis on sait
aujourd'hui que l'hiver va être tendu ça
vous ça veut dire quoi tendu
on sait qu'il y a un risque de coupure
ah bah voilà ce risque de coupure je
risque de coupure on fait tout nous
enedis et les autres acteurs du système
électrique
service public de la distribution
d'électricité pour éviter qu'il y ait et
ça fait partie des choses assez faciles
à mettre en oeuvre et qui vont avoir un
fort impact le seul fait de faire cela
c'est l'équivalent entre midi et deux
d'accord de la consommation d'une ville
comme Paris
impact et ça va faciliter le passage du
de ce cap là c'est ça qui est important
c'est qu'on applique une solution
technique qui n'a pas de conséquence sur
notre vie quotidienne de tous les jours
on met à disposition un outil qui permet
à chacun de bien maîtriser sa
consommation on est je crois on parle
beaucoup de sobriété c'est vraiment à
chacun de s'en saisir nous sommes ce
service public qui veut faire que tous
ensemble on arrive à passer cet hiver
plein de questions
est-ce qu'on va le passer cet hiver
parce que je sens que maintenant en ce
moment dès qu'on fait un truc si on sait
la guerre en Ukraine maintenant j'avais
des chaussettes trouées c'est la guerre
en Ukraine
Jean-Michel d'abord après
l'attention l'attention électrique en
France sera beaucoup conditionné par la
dureté de l'hiver à partir de combien de
à quelle température c'est ça on va être
en situation tendue parce que les gens
avant tout à partir de combien de degrés
5 degrés 0 - 5000 les coupures c'est
très très difficile c'est à peu près
certain c'est que la température
extérieure est un des sujets importants
l'ensemble de la filière parce que si
l'hiver est ce qu'ils disent Météo
France aujourd'hui voilà rien voilà a
priori tout va bien se passer
effectivement si on a un hiver sibérien
je peux pas le dire mais quel que soit
voilà
mais quelquefois on nous annonce des
hivers plus froids ils sont plus chauds
et inversement on sait bien qu'il fasse
ce qu'on appelle le réchauffement
climatique en fait c'est un dérèglement
climatique rien ne dit que cet hiver
sera particulièrement froid rien ne dit
que l'été prochain sera particulièrement
technicien et je suis j'agis pour
préserver le réseau
clients d'enedis et du réseau électrique
vous dites un hiver tendu s'il fait 5
degrés c'est pas comme si il faisait 20
degré donc comment on peut dire ça va
être tordu si il fait très beau il fait
pas froid et ça va tendu mais il fera
froid
donc vous dites ce sera tendu et oui bah
oui c'est Cyril ce sont les
verbes va être tendu effectivement comme
des Jean-Michel comme quoi
donc si fait cet hiver d'où il y aura
pas de tension mais malgré ça vous
pouvez penser que ça va être tendu donc
il y a un problème
je sais pas vous voulez dire ça va être
tendu
en avoir compris
l'échelle j'ai rien compris de ce qu'il
a dit je reviens ici je nage on ne
comprend rien est-ce que si quelqu'un
qui a compris ce qu'il a dit peut poser
la question
je vais essayer
je parle de Castaldi courant
tu as bien de la chance en fait
ce que je veux dire
[Rires]
c'est déjà beaucoup en fait il y a deux
choses parce que nous enedis nous
mettons en place pour faciliter le pas
se passage de l'hiver pour que chacun
puisse disposer l'électricité donc on
essaie lorsque c'est possible de faire
en sorte que il y ait moins de puissance
appelée et c'est le sens de cette de ce
choix technique qui a été fait en accord
avec les pouvoirs publics en effet parce
que nous sommes un service public et
c'est important que les choses se fasse
en cohérence mais c'est aussi chacun
d'entre nous qui doit prendre ses
responsabilités et agir pour une plus
grande sobriété énergétique chez soi au
quotidien c'est pour ça je ressors ce
que j'avais fait l'autre fois c'est
Cyril c'est que avec l'appli enedis à
mes côtés si je fais pas du business
c'est gratuit comme on peut tout le
monde peut la télécharger vous avez vous
avez votre conso à la demi-heure près
non mais je suis sérieux
un jour de qui pour attention je te jure
bon bravo Laurent il est très sûr mais
je pense comme vous quand même il est
très très bon
et il a raison mais c'est exactement
comme le covid une pilule qui va arriver
et c'est bien faites bien votre boulot
je vous explique pourquoi parce que vous
vous les avez les chiffres de quoi vous
avez besoin d'électricité pour les
hivers et pas me dire qu'il va faire 5
degrés à Strasbourg il fera pas 5 degrés
sur le plateau de langues il fera pas 5
degrés ah Clermont-Ferrand il fera pas
il fera moins 15 tu le savais très bien
que l'électricité que vous avez besoin
de François
e peut-être ils auront besoin moins de
chauffer mais il y a des villes où on
sait très bien dans l'Est vous le savez
vous les avez les chiffres et là vous
savez très bien que les chiffres par
rapport à vos réserves vous savez très
bien vous allez être obligé de couper
mais vous nous le dites pas et moi je
rejoins Cyril c'est le même couple le
covid
petit à petit vous les avez les chiffres
de consommation vous évoquez là c'est ce
qu'on appelle l'équilibre production de
consommation il faut dire que
l'électricité c'est quelque chose qui se
stocke pas ou très peu mais il faut qu'à
tout moment en France et même en Europe
ce qui est consommé par l'ensemble des
consommateurs d'électricité qu'il soit
particulier professionnel commerçants
entreprises industrie soit équivalent à
ce qui est produit c'est ça qui fait que
ça fonctionne s'il y a pas cet
équivalence le réseau il peut
s'effondrer et ça ne s'est jamais
produit en France oui mais là on est
dans une situation particulière si vous
voulez justement on veut éviter qu'il y
ait des coupures et qu'on ne soit obligé
de faire des coupures l'hiver prochain
et donc on prend toutes les précautions
pour que ça n'arrive pas
ce monsieur vraiment ce monsieur est
très bon
mais les plus grands spécialistes
annoncent la catastrophe si l'hiver est
plus froide d'habitude oui mais moi des
spécialistes j'en vois tous les jours je
veux bien c'est quoi des spécialistes
moi je suis je vous assure je suis le
porte-parole d'une entreprise de service
je suis là pour vous c'est la guerre en
Ukraine alors là bon je partirai pas sur
ce sujet-là c'est pas mon c'est pas mon
mental donc je suis pas content
non mais c'est ça moi je suis là pour
vous expliquer une décision qui a été
prise pour faciliter le passage de ma
mère et faire en sorte que chacun
d'entre nous puisse disposer de
l'électricité quand il en a besoin on a
un effort collectif c'est ce que nous
faisons et il y a des efforts
individuels à faire et vous avez des
outils disponibles pour pour le faire
alors et moi je vous les Français on les
Français qui nous rejoignent à 21h12
Laurent Méric porte-parole des needis
est-ce que vous pouvez nous dire à coup
sûr qu'il n'y aura aucune coupure
d'électricité d'eau pendant cet hiver ce
soir je suis là pour vous parler de la
décision prise sur le déclenchement
de chance que on est aucun problème je
vous assure aussi j'ai pas la
qualification pour ça je sais je peux
pas vous répondre ce sujet équilibre
production consommation il est géré par
RTE réseau de transports
RTE c'est eux qui nous disent ça serait
bien avec les pouvoirs publics que on
lisse la charge
on sait très bien qu'il va y avoir des
problèmes séculaires et je vais vous
dire ça démarre toujours par une
allocution du chef de l'État qui le dit
attention ça va être dur donc après les
autres prennent le relais et attention
ça va être très dur il y en a d'autres
crises voilà et c'est vrai que ils
essaient de nous préparer et c'est bien
parce qu'il nous voilà ils nous disent
pas ça et brutalement
pas assez fait attention on est obligé
de couper exactement
mais en vrai on sait très bien qu'on y
va on y va tout droit
alors il y a peut-être une question que
voilà vous pourrez me répondre
aujourd'hui les gens qui ont Linky c'est
soit les très bons citoyens qui sont
vraiment d'accord avec ça ou autrement
il y a les gens où vous êtes allés voilà
de degré ou de force limite des
résidences qui ont été violées pour
mettre de manière agressive ses
compteurs en place j'aimerais juste
parce que j'ai toujours rêvé d'avoir
quelqu'un de chez enedis en face de moi
pour lui poser cette question et donc
est-ce que vous êtes en accord avec
cette technique qui a eu lieu ou pas
avec la technique de Linky très très
agressive
c'est intéressant vraiment parce que je
me suis dit il y a quelque chose en
dessous et puis peut-être qu'on voit le
résultat de tout ça quoi franchement si
ça s'est produit je ne suis absolument
pas d'accord
de poser cette question
on a ça m'a posé 35 millions de
compteurs aujourd'hui il y a plus de 35
millions de compteurs en France
et les ont aujourd'hui chez eux parce
que rien qu'ici on a été plusieurs
parce que là il y a eu ce genre de
situation franchement c'est pas normal
j'en suis navré ce que je sais
aujourd'hui 35 millions de compteurs
vous avez une taux de satisfaction qu'on
mesure et qui est supérieur à 90 ou 92%
donc ça c'est une grande heureusement je
n'ai pas Linky
il y a des gens qui disent c'est à cause
de cet abruti de François Hollande je
vous jure que c'est vrai s'il n'avait
pas fermé les centrales nucléaires ça
pose cette abruti de François Hollande
position d'accord de lui d'accord
très bien surtout la vérité à cause de
François Hollande mais la pression des
écolos il a poussé à effectivement
fermer les centrales mais ça a été créé
après François Hollande donc si fermer
les centrales les centrales sont en
panne et on fait porter la
responsabilité sur les consommateurs les
factures augmentent 12 millions de
Français sont en galère énergétique
enfin on est le seul pays d'Europe à
avoir quand même un bouquet énergétique
qui nous fait payer certes l'électricité
trop cher mais beaucoup moins cher
contente
toujours content quoi non mais c'est
vrai il dort content quoi
demain on va te dire il y a plus rien
mais il nous reste des vaccins tu vas
être content non mais tu vas te faire
faire un vaccin pour avoir l'eau chaude
de mettre content d'ailleurs je fais le
vaccin j'aurais rien à [ __ ] on peut
tout caricaturer mais je préfère être
une citoyenne française aujourd'hui
qu'une
toujours contente non mais pas contente
benoîtement ou débilement content parce
que je compare autour de moi il parle
d'un vaccinité et tout ça
oui dernière question Laurent vous
parlez de la sobriété énergétique que
chacun doit respecter moi je suis pas
d'accord avec ça mais dites-nous
concrètement énergétique ça veut dire 19
degrés pas plus tout l'hiver vous
maintenez ça ceci vous le donnez on ne
pourra pas chauffer plus au risque de
nos enfants et froid
la sobriété alors chacun prend
conscience et fais attention sur les
gestes du quotidien voilà si chez vous
c'est 19 degrés c'est une bonne chose
c'est ce qui est préconisé mais si pour
des raisons qui vous sont propres vous
préférez chauffer un peu plus moi je
vais pas vous jeter la plante d'accord
si vos enfants ont besoin de 20 heures
[Rires]
le terme que j'ai employé de sobriété
énergétique il est vraiment important
parce que c'est un peu le sens et nous
inédites vraiment on veut être ce
service public de la sobriété
énergétique pour aider les dernières à
progresser dans ce cas moi j'ai une
dernière question merci Laurent d'avoir
été là est-ce que je dois derrière
quelque chose est-ce que tu penses que
je vais devoir passer tout l'hiver à
côté de Daniel Moreau